congressman devin nunes ranking member
of the house intel committee congressman
jim jordan
ranking member of house judiciary and
former clinton impeachment manager
bob barr congressman jordan um
now the process arguments of course
matter but
i think the weakness of the democrats
article of impeachment their single
article of impeachment
i wish the president trump's team
had spent more time just on that your
take
well yeah but they got across the main
message laura which is this is about
canceling the guy who got 74 million
americans to vote for him
they don't want him on the ballot in
2024 and they're so
focused obsessed i think it's the word
you use and that's the right word
they're so obsessed with that
they're willing to ignore the
constitution they're willing to ignore
due process
and they're willing to ignore the facts
which as you point out the president
said peacefully and patriotically
go down to the capitol and make your
voices heard i mean i think about this
past year laura
the democrats told us she couldn't go to
church you couldn't go to work you
couldn't go to a loved one's funeral
your kids couldn't go to school
and now they're trying to tell those
same same americans you can't vote for
the guy you want to vote for in 2024.
that's how obsessed they are i think the
american people see through it all
i think they understand that this is
ridiculous and as you said the
president's going to prevail here which
he should based on the constitution
the lack of due process and based on the
facts congressman barr
i thought i thought it was significant
that congressman siciline
refused to concede that the chief
justice
not showing up to preside was in fact
significant watch let me state
this very plainly it does not matter
it is not significant when the current
president is on trial
this president could preside and it
would be a conflict for someone to
preside over a trial that would become
president if there was a conviction okay
ken starr vehemently disagreed with that
uh last night on the show and said it is
entirely significant that the chief
justice
declined to be part of this your take
uh the chief well first of all chief
justices don't like to
sit on a p you know in impeachment
trials that was obvious uh a generation
ago when
justice rehnquist uh had to be sort of
dragged kicking and screaming to preside
over the clinton impeachment
uh and with the last impeachment uh
president trump uh also
it puts the chief justice in an
uncomfortable position
but the fact that this chief justice uh
properly reads the constitution that
they cannot
impeach by trial they cannot convict
a former president is very significant
otherwise
since president trump as president was
impeached
now they're going to try them if in fact
there was a constitutional basis for
that trial
the chief justice would be sitting in
that chair the fact that he is not
is very significant